226 squeeze aujourd'hui on se retrouve
pour la suite d'hélène relation on avait
donc pris l'ascenseur voilà après
maintes et maintes edc en boucle prédire
pour sécher les airs bordel et là qu'est
ce qu'on doit faire
ah non on est là qu'est ce qu'on doit
faire rétablir l'accès à la distribution
bien évidemment il ya un [ __ ] d'aliens
qui roule au dessus notamment dansé
conduit un ps qui peut pas partir faire
du cassoulet pour sa femme allait
annoncer photo qui reste de l'afp et un
alien s'empresser de ses eaux
on va crever ici nom ne soit pas
négative femme tu peux l'être maintenant
au nom maquette n'attaquez pas les
agneaux les civils
ah ouais à tora et est en train de se
plaindre tout sur son sort moi ça m'a
énervé alors ça doit être par ici
trouver le terminal de contrôle qui sont
laissés pour le garder synthétique et
dans une remise de vent et par pitié ne
fait pas de bruit à temps mais pourquoi
je fais autant de bruit quand je marche
là elle est armée ou quoi maintenant
amende à regarder 6 on a essayé pendant
des années devant coup toute la panoplie
en parallèle de sébastopol personnage
aurait vendu à l'action dans la sécurité
donc la sécurité toujours en ligne très
intéressant jackson oh mais c'est quoi
ça c'est quoi c'est un système d'
allahou c'est quoi bon journaux
chalumeau d'oxycoupage améliorer flamme
de place pas disponible
c'est là bas à gauche au un synthétique
il est gentil lui attend attendant
pourquoi les débris comme ça mettre la
pression pour rien voit pas se laisser
faire par leur manière de pression' et
les gens les gentils c'est bon très très
gentil même au fil des mois gentil monga
et bat nha nhac mais quoi sebbar et il
est parti loin loin loin loin alors
accéder au terminal qu'est-ce qu'elle
balade dans cette zone est interdite il
n'était pas avec nous finalement ce
[ __ ] d'android images de la caméra
et bien non voilà finalement on coupe la
caméra alors vite vite vite aller vite
vite vite fait c'est même distribution
c'est bon j'ai réussi
il fait chier fait chier ah ah mais vas
te faire activer disjoncteur de
laboratoire et fait disjoncter heures de
la salle de décontamination oui c'était
parle apparemment oui non tu veux pas
mais dès que je me casser le bras tu
veux montrer comment tu fais bien du
type windows tu vois je te connais pas
aa sauvegarde sauvegarde et je m'en vais
ma recette et sel et me dit pas qui
prend les échelles ce mec là est propre
à l'échelle c'est un android mais il est
pas assez malins en temps il faut y
aller désactiver la caméra sont très
malins ils mettent un moyen de
désactiver la caméra juste en dessous de
la caméra serait utile finalement merci
aux ingénieurs du 6e homme vraiment au
disjoncteur effectué direction le
laboratoire d'analysé d'un phoque moine
désactiver qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
là bas oya l'aliène dans la vienne on se
cache
j'ai pas envie de gâcher du
lance-flammes vous économisez notre
carburant qui n'a plus d'impôt que c'est
pas comme si habile et son cartable à
l'école là il faut attendre banon mais
c'est en fait on peut l'estimer on s'en
fout finalement hop organisé lise et
maintenant ils essaient lisez le conduit
de distribution [ __ ] faut retourner
tout là bas mais les gars vous arrêter
un moment vos conneries s'il vous plaît
non madame
mauvais choix ça faisait à pékin sa
pitance pourquoi tu te retires vélo à je
suis pas rassuré au mais non mais non
à revoir dans sa sauvegarde alors là
dedans même si juste à côté hockey il
viendra sourire domique tout il aime ça
regardez ça s'active et puis ça se
désactive
est ce que je fais on déjeune comprendre
en bref ce truc là est cassée voilà donc
du coup j'ai dû appeler lui pour qu'il
leur est pas bien évidemment l âge doit
activer de [ __ ] de levier sauf qu'il
ya ce truc là bas qui s'appelle un alien
et qui ne veut pas faire du tricot avec
moi ou encore faire des scoubidous non
ça n'intéresse pas il veut juste me
bouffe et voilà comme toujours on y va
on y vend dix ans on y va
allez allez allez comme ça c'est fait le
suivant le suivant boum ça c'est fait et
maintenant oui l'ascension est en ligne
replay tv vous vers un endroit appelé
projet kg 348 b2 dit pas qu'on vous y
serez oh [ __ ] il est là non on va
mourir
c'est quoi ça comment on passe ah non je
refuse un tel mépris de la part d'un
homme qui a craint de plus long que ma
[ __ ] et la fille comme un lâche
voilà comment on dégage ce truc là de
bien dans wii aux caisses juste là à
léocour alors là c'est le bordel total
je posterai ya un truc à faire pour
dégager le prochain truc qui nous bloque
parce que forcément un truc qui nous
bloque c'est l'ascenseur
direction projet kg 3 à 4 8 de b2 which
we wept jsui il est toujours derrière
vous je crois que je crois que oui j'ai
une idée allez au labo ok on va au labo
alors bonjour est ce que c'est un
laboratoire non c'est un endroit où
quelqu un est décédé déjà bien sûr ils
savent à quoi mon gars ça va être il est
là comme s'il n'y avait rien quoi comme
s'ils avaient pas d' alien comme si tout
allait bien
ouah daf un camé attendait mais ça c'est
une des premières salles dans laquelle
on a les noms il y avait un android et
c'est quelque chose du genre aux petites
musiques et tu fais du bien finalement
bonjour qu'as-tu sur toi du carburant
merci beaucoup
on a construit une mini u m messieurs
dames une [ __ ] de mines irm
voilà à quoi ça ressemble et voilà ça
c'est fait qui suivent ouais c'est bon
c'est là on peut séparer aussi passer
par les labos la cerise larmes étaient
en ligne et ce même quand on se
reconnecter à noyal aliens d'artois
marqué par tous partout au revoir
malienne allez allez allez voilà on est
bien en bas c'est parfait avec une
petite sauvegarde éventuellement
éventuellement là il faut rétablir le
courant dans le labo hockey en accès aux
labos mais charme so qu'on va jamais
s'en sortir dans ce [ __ ] de jeu sans
déconner l'âme sans que jamais on ne
reviendra sur terre tranquillement faire
des raquettes avec nos amis les skieurs
n'ont opt'in
un du carburant annoncée juste un
extincteur oh non non non non non moi
c'est beau ici en tête par là non oui
par la taille mais là on a fait un média
grand tour quoi et c'est là où il ya là
un nom dans la sauvegarde à 6 labelle
lebeau téléphone et ont été trouvés
maintenant hop c'est quoi rédélé le
disjoncteur voilà pour qui un petit peu
d'électricité dans tout ça parce qu'on
s'ennuie l'a finalement se baladent avec
des bougies à la main ça va pas ça y est
le coin est revenu maintenant on peut et
est ce thème du labo à sébastopol fuite
de matières dangereuses mais ça c'est
nickel
c'est moi que je vais mourir dans notre
souffrance avoir le même effet bâtarde
et ne pouvoir accéder directement à ce
magnifique un ordinateur à trois et
quatre cônes accepté alors qu'est-ce que
aux fuites de matières dangereuses se
confirmer oui d'accord s'échapper du
labo s'en désoler replay je te
pardonnerai jamais à ta phut tentant non
j'ai eu un truc c'est la liesse mais non
aux [ __ ] non oh non mais j'ai des
l'autre mec il s'est excusé parce qu'il
m'a largué finalement au l'enfoiré mais
non il m'a trahi quoi comme une vieille
merde
la trahison au nom alors je fais quoi je
vais crever non non
et du coup il a fait ça parce que du
coup la liane est avec moi et on a été
séparé du vaisseau white sale fils de
[ __ ]
mais [ __ ] faut que j'aille au ca c ou
le saas meilleur des oies [ __ ] c'est
génial
regardez coordonner notre action un peu
dangereuse mais d'attraction artois
bartois bartois bartois par toi j'ai pu
non non non non non non non non ce qu'on
vient de se faire violer par un [ __ ]
de droïdes là je comprends pas à l
annonce et voilà a tancé attend médias
nous répondre à ces messages et autres
ap mais qu'est ce qui met m'indiquer où
le saas est assez fermé pressurisée le
sas je fais ça comment travailler avec
nous à violetta leur comment on fait
c'est bon c'est bon
oh [ __ ] le bruit base y ait encore
plus de bruit 50% à temps et si je vais
dans le conduit c'est un bon plan ça bon
j'attends là ah bah voilà y'a pas de
quoi paniquer dans une situation
pareille à aller au saas avec un alien
juste au dessus c'est mon pays allait
enfin j'espère au fait pas tout mais
pierre la plus dense l'âme on a pu l'en
a' c'était chaud au alors comment ça se
passe pour le fermer
tac boum ça se ferme yes et maintenant
et maintenant est-ce qu'on est
tranquille et ce qu'on est enfin libre
en or ya un problème il nous faut une
combinaison il nous faut une combinaison
ça s'ouvre allait péter à ça va s'ouvrir
avant qu'on est dans la m c'est bon là
me relâcher cette question qu'est ce
qu'on fait oh là là là là bas le choc
s'est fait elle était plus forte que ça
allez allez allez allez
voila voila c'est très bien qu'on va
retourner donc dans une dans un vaisseau
bien évidemment dans lequel on va tous
aller toulouse
allez allez amanda ait eu tant sors tu
t'en sors
et voilà on s'en est sorti donc je pense
qu'on a vu on est retombé sur le
vaisseau d'or et sur lequel on était
avant que nous et jacques legros bâtard
alors du coup sortir la combinaison ok
c'est bon on est de retour dans le camp
des mandats replay et est ce que
quelqu'un m'entende
j'ai pensé vous wells c'est moi espèce
d'enfoiré qu'est ce que vous croyez je
n'ai pas le choix
vous avez cette chose a vu ce qu'il a
fait il fallait que je la sens de la
station quel que soit le prix à payer
est bien le prix à payer c'était souvent
pas sacrifier mon corps bobo corps
plutôt ouais même utilisé comme un pas
me laisser crever et ça a marché il
pleyber ça marche et je lui cette saleté
j'ai largué dans le géant gazeuse je
retourne au bureau on pourra parler de
méthode quand j serait terminé avant
d'aller pas contente
on peut le dire et moi je suis pas
content parce que j'ai pu tout blanc
s'enflamme à regarder et regarder
certains c'était dans la première ou
deuxième vidéo qu'on a été la fusée à
ponk louga on a infusée à propros la la
ça remonte loin ça c'est de cette salle
juste la droite on accéderait par un
ascenseur
oh [ __ ] en voilà ce que je fais ici
one of oak beach charge de taser à mon
avis du coup il ya plein d'android
partout allez on prend cet ascenseur
j'adore trouver l'autre là un mandat en
plus on a rouvert leurs essais de
recherche de taser autant vous dire
qu'on va le voir
ce boom que tu as fait j'espère qu'il va
mordre la poussière je n'aime pas cette
expression depuis 1978 ripley gps les
cards autour des tirs et oui et ricardo
pas grâce à white c'est un [ __ ] son
succès ça date pas d'hier c'est une
grosse tête de mule s'il m'avait pris la
peine de m'écouter on en sait peut-être
pas là bas ils tapent écouté mon grand
du coup là il faut qu'on rejoigne le
bureau et je pose ça va être une grande
épopée très risqué oh c'est bien beau tu
tiens ou moins la porte
les tableaux commandés store de sécurité
ah c'est ça maintenant c'est juste un
[ __ ] de robes ou notre manquement à
quoi je pensais que j'allais ouvrir le
score mais non en moins c'est prend
voilà il nettoie bien alors vous ne
venez donc se conduit à l'endroit où
rétablir le courant aux mines et aux mv2
bah voila j'ai pas jouer les rabat joie
mais il ya un problème est qu android
encore qu'est ce qui se passe avec ces
[ __ ] d'android depuis que je suis en
bas voilà oui je pense autre chose et
j'ai abandonné leurs postes
je viens de voir dans une veine public
ce pas normal super
ah ouais bah ouais gaffe à toi non mais
faut chine bordel c'est parti retourner
au bureau du marshall away attendait
c'est ce qu'on va faire
hop je prends aucun risque
manga aucun risque n'attaquez pas les
allées où les civils adacore je pensais
être le héros de l'histoire en fait j'ai
carrément tuer tous les civils
c'est parti à papa oh oh oh pardon les
autres huiles sont levés vont le
défoncer yes on n'est qu'un chien un bon
bah abonnements balle hors éléments par
ma faute mais non tient le bar olalalala
on est mal aux les endroits il te
tuerons mon gars le mec qui me tire
dessus il me dit je veux vous aider je
vais laisser android le défoncer bon
boulot à la chaise android dans la
nature et j'attaque à vue mais oui mexes
et de la voie qu il faut quoi à mon avis
ils veulent ils veulent buts et tout le
monde sait ça apollo a décidé qu'ils
android allés de leur but et tout le
monde oui ou alors moi du coucher un peu
dans la merde je me moque mais un
android en feu oh la la la la tête mais
bon c'est la vie tu mérites la sentence
vu ta soeur c'est une blague il est
encore à temps mais elle se mêle de
rejoindre dans un film quoi est
carrément beaux acteurs une cascadeur
professionnel
abbas était juste là ça c'est fait me
dis pas que tu es un civil monga j'y
crois pas heureusement que j'ai raté
c'est un civil
or c'est bon les gars chez avec vos
chèques vous calmez vous allez venez bon
bah allez mourir sauvegarde colonies
alma chose ça doit être par là je n'en
peux plus white s'il ya des stands
sécurité qui barrent la route vous
pouvez ouvrir
oui c'est bon enfant ils sont bonnes
moeurs ou et laissez les tranquilles
arrêté ice ont attaqué mes potes os et
android
hop au quai ouest vont mourir trouve un
chemin alternatif de paris qui si un
truc s'est débloqué comme c'est un peu
sauvegardés par exemple cette pièce par
exemple cette porte juste là où je suis
libre ya quelqu'un ici n'ont jamais
aller juste vue de retourner dans le
poste des marshall et de voir si white
est mort elle fait pas culpabiliser fait
pas son nom le savez très bien ils
s'attendaient pas à ce qu'on fasse des
bébés avec cet alien un certain du tout
à ce que cet élève mettre son bébé en
nous et qu'on crève ça c'est android qui
fait la sieste
là c'est une c5 omaha
mais non à quel moment ça m'enlève de la
vie il va juste prix la cheville quoi à
toi mais là on oppose démarche à la
sauvegarde ya pas un androïde ici tu
aimes bien y'a un mec là bas encore vais
plus ils sont tous morts et saintronic
les androïdes les ont massacrés quoi
[ __ ] pourquoi [ __ ] pourquoi je ne
sais pas ça mais je dois le savoir une
toile sa vraie c'est clair olala taylor
marleau ils sont pas ici reste ici
déroulés porte et sont les personnes
occupe toi de me guider je reviendrai de
chercher le ricard dont il va rester au
poste d marshalls et moi je vais devoir
encore comme d'habitude me balader et
peut-être mourir dans d'atroces
souffrances on sait pas où je trouve
samuel hop là ça me met mon amour tu
n'es pas samuel ça me laisse a des
cheveux courts du coup là il n'y a plus
la lienne sur le vaisseau mais bon il ya
quand même six mille android au final
c'est parce qu'elle mieux on appelle le
transit et ont rejoint samuel notre
amoureux enfin et là du coup on appuie
sur le bouton et beaumont va à la
tourette et m'aide c'est matt boyle et
on y retrouvera samuel et il embrassera
langoureusement mais c'est un endroit
des contrats des bd mieux mais
reviendront pas nos voix l'agencé dire
fin de cet épisode sur l'innovation chez
saks n'a plus comme d'habitude c'est
qu'elle n'y est pas et les vidéos je
pense qu on a peut-être une chambre sans
sortir un moment donné la liait n'est
plus dans l'histoire mais parcours
d'android se sont accouplés de manière
naturelle
il y aura juste des bijoux un peu
partout on se retrouve très vite dans
une nouvelle vidéo chat au monde pis